c'est le nouveau quotidien d'un ami paul
la première femme noire à la tête du
parti et fédérales la chef des verts
veut profiter de sa victoire historique
pour se faire connaître c'est votre
combien
94 car il y a quelques semaines à peine
elle était encore une parfaite inconnue
la scène politique canadienne
ok on y va c'est là où vous habitez ça
oui bon c'est ceux là où j'ai passé
toute mon enfance un ami paul a grandi
ici dans ce petit appartement du
nord-ouest de toronto
vous étiez combien l'intérieur ont
officié à 6 oui on couchait dans le
salon 3 dans un lit d'un seau d'eau sur
un sofa plions issu d'une famille
immigrante antillaise et l'apprendre
français dès l'école primaire
ma mère est elle qui a décidé à qu'il
faut absolument que ses enfants soient
bilingues
parce que c'est un pays miné après des
études en droit à l'université d'ottawa
elle est admise à la prestigieuse
université princeton aux états unis
c'est là où elle se convertit au
judaïsme la religion de son mari
avec nos deux enfants nous avons décidé
un peu pour pour le travail mais aussi
pour la monture avant d'aller à
travailler en belgique un ami paul reste
treize ans en europe
elle travaille notamment à la cour
pénale internationale de la haye en
janvier 2019
elle rentre au canada et commence à
militer au sein du parti vert son
engagement politique est largement
influencée par ses origines modestes
aussi on crée des politiques sur le
logement abordable
alors ça ça vaut la peine d'inclure des
perspectives des personnes qui ont
grandi dans les situations comme comme
comme la mienne et celle de notre
famille un ami paul est consciente que
la crise climatique ne doit pas être le
seul enjeu qui définit le parti vert
elle veut mettre de l'avant la justice
sociale nous sommes le parti
progressiste au canada ça c'est ça c'est
une faire mon travail c'est de
communiquer ça pour moi c'est le moment
de dire aux canadiens canadiennes
regardez notre politique sur le revenu
minimum garanti
nos politiques ça universel sur halak
sam les médicaments tous ces choses
qu'il faut ham qui a qui sont
nécessaires pour aura complété notre
filet social
mais le défi est énorme pour elles parce
que lors de la dernière élection le
parti vert a eu beaucoup de mal à
s'organiser et à s'imposer face aux
autres formations politiques qui ont
elles aussi fait de l'environnement et
de la justice sociale
des éléments importants de leur
plateforme on sait que les canadiens
canadiennes sont attirés par nos
politiques mais il faut qu'ils se sont
confiants que nous sommes prêts à
gouverner et si loin d'être acquis
en attendant la femme de 47 ans savoure
sa victoire comme chef son fils avec qui
elle a fait campagne mesure l'importance
du moment mais je vois vraiment là le
symbole historique qu'est sa victoire
mais aussi ce que ça veut dire pour
beaucoup de personnes pour les personnes
pour la communauté noire pour
l'économique communauté juive pour la
communauté immigrante en 2001 qu'il ya
des filles qui m'écrit pour dire j'ai
jamais à bon à votre victoire j'ai
jamais imaginé qu'ils auraient une place
pour moi dans la vie politique
elle espère surtout qu'elle sera à la
hauteur de sa nomination histo
ici laurence martin radio-canada taureau